welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
analytical variations old problem new
consequences presented by Matt Haskin
CEO of service analytics and founder of
canna safe analytics
my name is Xavier courtiers and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to attend your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming Matt Haskin I will
now turn the presentation over to Ed all
right thank you thank you to lab roots
to have the opportunity to present today
and for all of you that are taking time
to come and listen to I have to say so
today I wanted to just kind of briefly
discuss what we call analytical
variation this is an old old problem it
goes way back in all industries but it
has you know new consequences right now
to to our emerging commercial cannabis
market all right so my name again is
Matt Haskin I was the founder and former
CEO of canna safe analytics that was the
first cannabis lab in the world to
become accredited to the ISO 17025
standard and that was back in 2012
recently I opened a second laboratory
called service analytics we are licensed
by the BCC and ISO accredited as well
so lab roots gave me the topic of the
most challenging lab related issues of
2019 okay and so in kind of thinking
about what that may be there's a lot of
obviously challenging in this emerging
you know industry with complex matrices
of the cannabis plants you know I'm
thinking about all the different methods
that we had to develop there are no
published methods so over the years you
know there was obviously method
development and validation working with
complex and ever-expanding matrices
especially in edible formats right we
see everything from you know the baked
goods the cookies the ice creams to beef
jerky to popcorn
you know tablets you name it you know
we've seen it we've had to figure out
how to you know extract the the analyte
of interest in this case our
cannabinoids and recover those and
analyze those I so credit Asian is
always a challenge I feel all these have
been passed challenges so therefore I
want to talk about you know a challenge
that has been with us the lab industry
and with me since day one and that is
obviously you know where we come into
the topic of analytical variation okay
so what is analytical variation
analytical variation is essentially the
differing of results between two labs or
the difference in results inside the
same lab for the same sample all right
so we have inter lab and intra lab and
you know we wonder how does that happen
how can one sample have two different
measurements if you will right we're
measuring an analyte where that's THC or
CBD or even a pesticide compound how
could it have two different measurements
well that is kind of the topic of
discussion today and what causes that
how do we you know move forward knowing
there's always going to be analytical
variation and you know what can we do
about it best practices and how can
regulators and Industry participants you
know work within these parameters
so the causes of variation in
measurements right obviously we have a
big one lack of industry standardization
so there are no standard methods or
published methods that every lab would
then adhere to so we have each lab
essentially has their own validated
hopefully validated method that they're
working with there's been a big push for
standardization at some point it'll come
that's just one of the areas I don't
think that is the overriding cause but
it's one obviously validated
methodologies right so we're all using
our own methods if they're not validated
there's gonna be major variants amongst
results at that point what's the
difference in our quality management
systems our QA QC how do we adhere to
those quality management systems to
create reproducibility in our
measurements and then of course we have
the technical competence of staff and
qualifications of staff okay and I think
one be most important that I want to
dive into a little bit deeper today is
what we call the uncertainty of
measurement right so this is part of the
analytical variations we have an
uncertainty of measurement and within a
lab we call that our uncertainty budget
okay so all measurements have an
uncertainty regardless of the precision
or the accuracy of the measurement right
there is very there are very few true
measurements right they must be
traceable back to NIST and in the case
of cannabis you will never have a
cannabis plant a cannabis product with a
true known value okay we'll have a
measurement of that value and we our
goal is to get it as close and precise
to the true value as possible
understanding that there will be air
right so we're going to talk about
different ways that we do that okay and
the difference between the measured
value and the true value is what we call
an air the air or the bias so what
contributes to the measurement
uncertainty okay first of all we have
two categories essentially it's one is
trueness trueness is the estimate of
that measurement
estimate of the systematic error okay so
systematic would be our instrument for
example a GC or an LLC or an HPLC right
if we take that instrument in one sample
and we inject it ten times the exact
same sample there will be a deviation
some type of variation that the incision
is the estimate of the random error
random error is essentially human error
right so knowing those two things okay
we can determine our uncertainties and
the uncertainty is what every lab should
have for almost every compound that they
vision okay we need to understand what
contributes to this uncertainty so again
we just spoke about it we have
analytical instruments which is
systematic again our HPLC S or GCS L
CMS's we have our sap sample prep
instruments right this is both random
and systematic because we use calibrated
measuring tools such as pipettes
analytical balances okay in an ISIL
credited laboratory all our measuring
tools and instruments are calibrated by
another accredited calibration lab at
least annually and then alien weekly
they have internal checks and logs that
we maintain to ensure that we are
creating as small as an uncertainty
based on a weight or a volume as we can
and that's all in the sample prep of the
sample of course our technicians right
your staff and your technicians your
technical staff that's the random error
that is human error that's just inherent
and anything that we do as human beings
in sampling a representative sample you
know we have statistical sampling
protocols to get the most representative
sample as possible but when you're
dealing with 50 pounds of biomass and
we're taking 80 grams of that biomass as
a representative sample so again random
error in the sampling and then finally
we have certified reference material
that's the closest we have
to a true value right so that certified
reference material or standard as we
call it is where we kind of base our
measurement from all right so that will
be the basis of our measurement and it's
the closest reference we have to a true
value so when we have these results in
variation of measurement what does that
mean so let's just say for example in a
you know in cannabis flower right we
have the same sample could be 16.5% from
one lab one lab could come back and say
it's 19.4 per sec okay we have a
chocolate you know an infused chocolate
maybe the target was a hundred
milligrams one lab could say it's ninety
to one lab could say it's a hundred and
eight okay that represents a plus or
minus heir of a percent with an overall
swing of 16 percent so now you see where
it starts to seem dramatic however it's
a plus or minus of eight percent and in
our uncertainties we don't understand if
it's a plus or minus and there are no
Corrections for that it's simply plus or
minus so if the if the true value of
course we wouldn't know this of that
cannabis flower was 18 percent one lap
could measure it at 16 five and the
second time they ran it could be 19 four
okay so those are some of the
frustrating obviously frustrating
components for the producers cultivators
and so forth but what we're getting into
now the new consequences of this
variation are what you see there on the
summary and that would be a fail right
when your product or your crop fails
regulatory testing now you're looking at
destroying 50 pounds of flour
potentially a hundred and fifty thousand
units of a finished product which could
be vape cartridges you know you're
talking hundreds of thousands if not a
million dollars it has to be destroyed
because you failed a test now could that
test have been what could you have
failed that test based on you know some
measurement
uncertainty it's quite possible it's not
always the reason but it's quite
possible so when I use these examples of
plus or minus 8% you can see there that
is the criteria that is set for
prescription drugs in pharma okay plus
or minus eight percent meaning you know
your 100 milligram oxycontin I don't
know if they come in that strength but
100 milligram you know prescription drug
it could be 92 or it could be a hundred
eight you know I think most of us take
those prescription drugs at face value
and it says a hundred milligrams we
believe we're getting a hundred well the
reality is it's not unlike what we deal
with every day there is a variation and
in their tolerance is plus or minus
eight percent at this one so the basis
of our measurements is come from our
certified reference materials right our
standards the closest we have to a true
value that we know so again we would
take that as gospel we get a reference
standard for THC thousand
parts-per-million 1000 ppm we assume
it's 1000 ppm we use that reference
standard to set the curve you'll see the
middle box there and the slide is our
calibration curve these I just pulled
off the internet they're just examples
but this is an example of a calibration
curve right and all those points are
different concentrations of that THC
standard for example with the high point
being a thousand parts per million and
maybe that low point at the very bottom
being one part per million to the right
of that is the chromatogram once the
sample is put on to the either HPLC or
the GC you know it's going to separate
all the compounds that is the purpose of
chromatography to separate the compounds
and then we read the the abundance
underneath the the peak right the area
under the peak will determine its
concentration we matched that to our
calibration curve and voila we give
the measurement okay so using that
certified reference materials you see is
extremely important in to the final and
determination you know of the of the
measurement so now we're gonna take a
look at this is a CoA
certificate of analysis on certified
reference material for Delta 9 THC and
in this example I'm using absolute
standards reference material absolute
standards has been around for decades
they have been in the you know the
reference material and chemical business
for for years and years quality they
hold every accreditation possible so I'm
not picking on them I'm just using them
to show some examples here so in this
certified reference material CoA for our
Delta 9 standard okay and I apologize I
don't have a pointer but if you look in
the middle of that CoA you'll notice
some things were they already they
outline their uncertainties they have an
uncertainty due to their balance I
believe they have an uncertainty you
know within their pipettes and they have
a flask uncertainty now again I
apologize I can't point this out but if
we go to the numbers about the middle of
the screen and you slide to the right
you'll notice what's called the expanded
uncertainty okay and in this case if you
can see the expanded uncertainty is
eight point zero micrograms per
milliliter which equals ppm so we have
an 8 ppm uncertainty within our
reference standard this is a specific
lot by the way so that 1,000 High Point
could have been 1008 it be 992 we're
using it as 1,000 okay now same company
two different Lots so now total of three
different Lots we've looked at of the
same Delta 9 THC standard you'll see on
one of these if you can find that spot
again down in the middle of the numbers
we have nine point four so in this lot
now we have an uncertainty of nine point
four parts per million all right and
then the next one to the right to see a
way to the right same company same Delta
nine reference standard lots a lot we
haven't eight parts per million nine and
a half parts per million and over
fifteen parts per million as a deviation
an uncertainty in that measurement I
mean you know no other variations we
have you know a deviation of up to 1.5
percent already in our reference
standard okay so and this is the same
company now we have multiple companies
that offer certified reference material
and they're all going to vary so my lab
is running which reference standard my
lab ran which lot it came from there'll
be a variation to the next laboratory or
even the next time you bring in the
exact same sample there could be a
variation because I may be on a
different lot of reference standard
right so that's extremely important to
understand now we get into and that okay
this is for potency so you know there
are some economic you know benefits to
higher potency right we get a little you
know maybe that you get a better
purchase price for your products you
know maybe you win a cannabis cup you
know or you have bragging rights okay
that's that's all good but you know now
we get into maybe some of the more
serious you know side effects of this
variation we talked about which would be
a fail and now you're destroying you
know a lot of product a lot of money so
we're gonna just go ahead and take a
peek now at a pesticide reference
standard right potency is one thing now
we have pesticides by fen is a very
popular pesticide it's flora mite is the
trade name for it hopefully no longer
used but still very prevalent
soleares two again two different Lots
from the same company and the variation
again out of a thousand of concentration
of a thousand parts per million in one
lot 10.8 parts per million variation
plus or minus that's plus or minus 1%
variation in our standard another lot 27
okay 2.7 percent just in our reference
standard for that pesticide analyte and
just to point out you see the California
action limit for by feni's 8 in inhaled
products is 0.1 parts per million 100
parts per billion is the action limit
anything over that fails yeah we're
measuring these products you know with a
benchmark that has a plus or minus 27
parts per million so quickly and in
conclusion you know I just want to just
have that little brief discussion to
make everybody aware that you know this
uncertainty of measurement is something
that you know you need to work with your
lab on you find labs and talk to your
lab about their uncertainties it's
called an uncertainty budget you can ask
your lab they should have that for you
work with them on how do you use your
best practices to to work within those
parameters if there's a plus or minus of
five 10% you know how do you formulate
based on that probability that that you
can add that uncertainty from your lab
okay so this is where you need to
partner with your lab and really really
develop a relationship and work with
them we obviously you know as labs we do
it's called proficiency testing to
always ensure our you know accuracy if
you will in our you know limiting our
air and our measurement I think it's
important here obviously for for
lawmakers and regulators you know to
understand and account for these
uncertainties of measurement while
they're creating laws while they're
creating regulations you know do we need
some plus or minus and air we have that
in edibles in
plus or minus 10% which i think is a
fair you know a fair a fair acceptance
range for that so again a challenge of
this just in recapping all this the
challenge for the laboratory is very
similar to the challenge for the you
know the participant the client is that
you know it's frustrating it's maddening
at times that that the you know you feel
that the same sample Gaz a different
measurement and certainly a wider swing
when it goes in between labs and it is
nothing new to the laboratory or
analytical chemistry it feels new to a
you know fledgling industry such as the
cannabis industry but you know we
certainly look to narrow that range but
we just need to learn that then you know
there is a there is a level and a
variation in that and to work within
those variations and I appreciate your
time thank you so much and I'll be happy
to answer any questions thank you Matt
for that informative presentation and I
would also like to think lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible and as a final reminder our
speaker will follow up with any
questions you've submitted via email
that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon good right